une trêve semble encore bien loin dans
la bande de gaza ici des frappes
israéliennes sur un camp d'entraînement
des brigades al qassam l'explosion
subséquentes porte à croire qu'il s'agit
là d'une cache d'armes
un peu plus tôt le brasier se consumait
toujours quand fouad yassine est revenue
constater les dégâts d'une autre frappe
la veille la famille voisine a reçu un
appel des forces israéliennes
vous devez quitter votre maison leur
at-on dit elle sera frappée dans 15
minutes
aussitôt les six familles qui habitaient
l'édifice ont plié bagage
fouad sa femme et ses onze enfants aussi
dix minutes plus tard ils ont lancé deux
roquettes d'avertissement dit il dix
minutes peut-être un peu moins après ils
ont frappé avec un f 16
j'étais là bas raconte il des débris de
roquettes sont parvenus jusqu'à nous des
singles comme celles ci sont tristement
familière à tel point que les gens du
quartier nous ont dit de se sentir à
l'abri nulle part sur les six famille
qui habitait cette maison
l'une d'entre elles avait justement
trouvé refuge ici la maison de fouad a
été épargnée mais il ne veut plus y
habiter ok je suis sûr qu'ils vont
frapper quelque part chez mes voisins
chez moi je ne sais pas mais je sais que
leurs missiles vont frapper j'ai peur
les enfants ont peur ils pleurent mais
que peut-on faire de mon team ils sont
maintenant plus de 140000 gazaouis
déplacés par la férocité des combats
dans ces écoles des nations unies
transformé en refuge
la famille souba partagent une classe
avec une quarantaine de parents et
voisins
la roma est à l'honneur c'est du pareil
au même d'issoire j'ai peur ici j'ai
peur là bas il tire ici là bas il tire
partout à trois reprises depuis lundi
deux écoles comme celles ci ont été la
cible de tirs israéliens selon les
apparences dénonce l'onu qui demande une
enquête
les forces israéliennes n'ont pas
commenter pour l'instant ce sont censés
être des endroits protégés dit il et
nous les avons indiqué aux forces
israélienne ou ces gens viennent à nous
parce qu'ils se croient plus en sûreté
c'est extrêmement inquiétant dans cette
confiance est visible
pour le moment les subban n'ont guère
d'autre choix
nous n'avons pas besoin de cessez le feu
d'un ou deux jours ou même donne en dit
nauman nous avons besoin de sentir que
nous pouvons vivre comme tout le monde
bâtir des maisons un avenir ils ne
seront pas sans cesse écrite et sa
maison il devra la rebâtir au moins une
autre fois depuis sa fuite
hélas été rasé par un bombardement